biden got some welcome economic news on
friday following the release of the
latest unemployment numbers which are
inching closer to pre-pandemic levels
the economy added 431 thousand jobs in
march that's the 11th straight month of
job growth over 400 000 and that ticked
the unemployment rate down from 3.8
percent to 3.6 percent the lowest has
been since the start of the pandemic but
high gasoline prices are also fueling
concerns as the nation seen the largest
inflation spike in 40 years scott
mcfarland is at the white house with the
very latest scott good morning michelle
good morning to you the biden
administration is celebrating this
weekend that new jobs report and those
400 000 new jobs but at the same time
it's watching gas prices soar
president biden will begin his weekend
trip to delaware attending the
commissioning ceremony of a navy
submarine today after celebrating a jobs
report showing the job market is
cruising good morning the president
wasted no time touting the good
unemployment news with the unemployment
rate down to 3.6
over the course of my presidency
our recovery has now created 7.9 million
jobs
more jobs created over the first 14
months of any presidency in any term
ever
a surge of openings in leisure and
hospitality in particular and nearly two
job openings for every unemployed
american and paychecks are getting
fatter wage is up more than five percent
in march
but that's not keeping up with inflation
with more of that take-home pay getting
siphoned at the gas pump
unleaded averaging well over four
dollars a gallon but it will come down
and it could come down fairly
significantly the administration is
waiting to see if this week's
announcement of tapping into strategic
oil reserves lowers the prices but in
the meantime
it's not just americans but the public
schools getting a test in economics how
stressful is it when you see diesel get
close to five dollars a gallon operating
all these diesel vehicles it's stressful
because you have to go back and look at
your budget like okay we're going to
make it nationwide schools from
montgomery county maryland to michigan
to new york are considering revised bus
routes to conserve fuel newport news
virginia will operate fewer buses by
extending the maximum ride for kids from
60 minutes to 90.
the biden administration has announced
new fuel standards for traditional cars
and trucks requiring better gas mileage
by the 2024 models the administration
argues that could save drivers hundreds
of dollars each year
at the pump michelle
they're looking for that saving money
scott thank you so much